Speaker 1: Well, yesterday we started the show
with this disastrous news out of Italy in which
a far right nationalist group with individuals
within it, like Georgia Moloney, who have neo
fascist roots and origins in their sort of
political lives, are coming to power in Italy.
And we also talked a little more broadly about the
origins and the catalysts for this rightward shift
in Italy. It shouldn't surprise us that in the 24
hours following the news of what's taking place in
Italy, American right wingers who of course don't
claim to be fascists or neo fascists or anything
of the sort, have rallied behind Georgia Maloney
in some cases, without even actually knowing what
her name is, Marjorie Taylor GREENE, referring
to her as Giorgio. Maybe she thinks it's a man.
I don't really know, but we'll get to that in a
moment. And saying that this is a great thing,
that there is the rise of the right in Europe,
which is not altogether wrong. In fact, we talked
about that yesterday, but also pretending as
though Georgia Maloney and her party are just
kind of mainstream individuals rather than the
extreme rightists that they are. So let's take a
look at a couple of clips. First, here is Charlie
Kirk on the Charlie Kirk show saying this isn't
fascism. Georgia Maloney and her ideology, this is
middle of the road. Common sense. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Here, of course, on the
American media. Is Georgia Maloney
being called a fascist on MSNBC? Yeah,
they're all for democracy until somebody
who they don't like wins and then they call.
Speaker 1: Well, there's there's two different
things here, right? You can be a fascist who won
through democratic means. Now, she's not literally
a fascist, but she was a member when she was
younger of the youth front. That's a neo fascist.
It's the youth wing of a neo fascist political
party called the Italian Social Movement. It's
it's not a question of opinion. It's what it is.
Speaker 2: A person Mussolini got 35.
The victory of a party that has its roots in
Italian fascism, plain and simple. The brothers of
Italy, it's called Giorgio Meloni's party, though,
is concerning to everybody. It accompanies, as you
said, this move in Europe. I think that in Sweden,
a party with right wing neo fascist roots would
now be dominant and in parliament. It's sweeping
all across Europe and they can't figure out why
it's not fascist. It's common sense.
It's normal. It's middle of the road.
It's about things that are eternally important,
not about gender theory. Postmodernist constructs,
squashing the imperialist colonialist
history. No, no, no. This is about
things that transcend all of that.
Speaker 1: And this is a perfect example
of exactly how these parties become popular.
We talked about this yesterday. We talked about
exactly this. This is what they do. This is
the type of stuff that they say, oh, these are
about the real issues. You've got to be afraid of
immigrants from other countries. We've got to stop
the gender stuff by saying that this is normal.
He is proving exactly the point we made yesterday.
Speaker 2: The American political scene is going
through the exact same thing now. And we now, you
see. The globalists are the globalists.
Speaker 1: The globalists. There it is.
Speaker 2: The unit party. They have
to do everything they possibly can.
To try and thwart this movement.
Speaker 1: Now, we're going to get back to that
in a moment. But it was not just Charlie Kirk,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE tweeting congratulations to
Joe Maloney and to the people of Italy, of course,
just another one of Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Typos,
as usual and radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert tweeted, quote, This
month, Sweden voted for a right wing government.
Now Italy voted for a strong right wing
government. She has to acknowledge that in Italy,
it's even further right. But she can't use the
term neo fascist. The entire world is beginning
to understand that the woke left does nothing but
destroy. November eight is coming soon and the USA
will fix our House and Senate. Let freedom reign.
This is a hard right ideology that dabbles
into neofascism. Now, in the last 24 hours,
there have been many enlightened centrists and
others who have come out of the woodwork and said
it's not really fascism, Georgia Melania. It's
the brothers of Italy. It's not really fascism,
no, but it has its origins in fascism. Maloney
joined the Youth Front, which is the youth
wing of the neo fascist political party,
the Italian social movement MSSA in 1992.
They've taken these extreme nationalist positions,
hard line against immigration, put out the Italian
navy to patrol the water and block migrants from
arriving by sea. Vox has written that Maloney's
victory will roll back minority rights, including
the rights of women, LGBTQ people and migrants.
It's the typical hard right package. The brothers
of Italy used the insignia and the slogan God,
Country, Family, which is an echo to its fascist
predecessors. She's against abortion. She's
against same sex marriage. She's against same sex
parenting. She's against multiculturalism. In May
of 2020, she praised Giorgio Al Morante, who's
the co-founder of the Italian Social Movement,
which is that group, that neo fascist group I told
you about. Al Miranda was a Nazi collaborator and
editor in chief of an anti-Semitic and racist
magazine, which published something called The
Manifesto of Race. There's a lot of this stuff.
Melania has praised the Italian dictator Mussolini
as a, quote, good politician, the best of the
last 50 years. That was in a French newscast
in 1996. So this stuff is not just being made up
out of thin air. This is the reality. And what's
happening is a sort of rewriting of history. Some
people don't really know that much about Italian
fascism. Others are easily convinced that this
has nothing to do with it. But the roots of this
movement are Italian fascism. That's the reality.
And so certainly you can make the case she is not
a fascist per se, and I'm with you. But this is a
hard right group with its origins in terms of the
individuals that make it up in neo fascism and
even worse. And it shouldn't shock us even for
a second that the right wingers are jumping
to defend it because they've openly, openly
romanticized these types of
movements during the Trump era.